alors on va prendre l'ascenseur qui va
prendre l'escalier je prends l'ascenseur
l'escalier quoi et voulez et vous la
l'ascenseur ces éléments c'est du
cinquième étage où ça le premier arrive
à bas il y aura une tarte
le premier arrivé en bas aura le droit
de mettre la tarte dans la tête de
l'autre d'accord vous êtes prêts voilà
c'est parti au liban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les sages
entre le corps
[Applaudissements]
quand l'ascenseur bébé sortie de crise
et le jeu qui vous jouez léger on a
retiré tous les jours je vois le joker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya vincent moscato et jean françois
quéré qui étaient avec nous demain c'est
aujourd'hui sur le timon voulait tout
casser
ils sont dans le tarn ascenseur leuthard
d'ascenseur donc je sais pas qui va
prendre l'ascenseur qui va prendre les
escaliers les droits de brassage prend
l'ascenseur qui prend les escaliers
bah c'est lui qui prend l'ascenseur nom
et vous prenez les escaliers moi je sors
il va avoir un accident dans cette
émission était tout à fait sûre et
certaine mais c'est sûr et certain
ça va mal se terminer on va s'assurer
l'habitude faso et alors on y va
c'est mardi jean françois et vincent dit
pas c'est gratuit
[Applaudissements]
amazon
attention et ses avatars qui veut qu'ils
attendent derrière l'ascenseur a dit lui
c'est qu'elles peuvent blesser ou dégâts
il ne fait que c'est pas parce qu il
il est arrivé mais il est pas
[Applaudissements]
ça valait le terrier
attendez attendez attendez il va tenter
je vous paye a tous bien sûr le pressing
you lie qui a été touché